okay so there are these poles that
become more and more popular the closer
we get to the primaries and eventually
to Election Day and they are called
hypothetical matchups if the Democratic
nominee were Biden would you vote for
Biden or Trump if the Democratic nominee
were Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
would you vote for Bernie or Warren or
would you vote for Donald Trump and the
idea is to start getting an assessment
not just of who's popular within the
Democratic primary but who might fare
better in the general election against
Donald Trump
now all the normal caveat sand
disclaimers have to be applied
we are still what is it 14 months out
from the election
these are not going to be necessarily
the same numbers that we would get in
November of 2020 they still don't
account for what would potentially take
place geopolitically and domestically
between now and the election but it's an
idea gives us a sense of sort of where
things are with some of these
hypothetical matchups CNN did the most
deceptive thing where they put up the
result results out of order which just
so happened to make Bernie Sanders look
far weaker than he actually is so first
I'm going to play the clip from CNN then
we'll look more closely at the images
and the important thing to know is that
this is information from a Quinnipiac
poll and according to this Quinnipiac
poll the Democrat would the biggest lead
against Trump is Biden Biden is plus
sixteen over Trump in this poll now it
doesn't matter whether you believe it or
not because the point is is CNN
accurately representing the results
Biden is plus sixteen Bernie is plus
fourteen over Trump and Warren is plus
twelve
meaning Bernie is second in terms of the
size of his lead against Trump in a
hypothetical matchup in this poll let's
take a look at the CNN clip and a large
lead for all of the Democratic
frontrunner there tell us what this news
means for the president how seriously
are they taking these numbers I mean
what what Harry was pointing to with the
economy I think that I mean that number
is problematic for sure for the
president okay so now let's
look at the way that they show the
results on screen remember the order is
Biden plus 16 Burnie plus 14 Warren plus
12 but for whatever reason they show
Biden then Warren and then Sanders now
they're not lying about the numbers when
you look at the numbers the numbers of
the right numbers but why is it in this
order and then you'll notice over to the
right side of the screen our Harris and
Buddha jej who have even smaller leads
over Trump than Warren in the
hypothetical poll so this is not a story
where I want to talk about how much is a
hypothetical poll worth in August of the
year before the election this is not me
wanting to talk about is Biden gaining
or falling or can we believe that Biden
is plus 16 over Trump all I'm talking
about is this is a data point and the
question is how is it that CNN came up
with this order for how they displayed
the results no matter whether you're
displaying the results in two columns or
in two rows alphabetically there is no
way that Bernie Sanders would be at the
bottom of the screen even in
alphabetical order
Bernie with Abby Sanders with an S he
would not be at the bottom of the screen
his lead is bigger than Warren's his
lead is bigger than Cowell Harris's his
lead is bigger than Pete Budaj edges his
first name starts with a be his last
name starts with an S there is no
explanation for why Bernie Sanders name
is at the bottom of the screen now do I
think that this is a deliberate attack
on Bernie Sanders by CNN I don't know
honestly not really I know people are
saying oh CNN is now choosing war and
they've anointed Warren as the non Biden
person that they're going to promote
maybe hey I don't know that it's that
calculated but it just always seems to
not quite work out in Bernie Sanders
favor in these things maybe there is
some deliberate nature to it either way
whether it's on purpose negligence
indifference incompetence it's another
one of these subliminal digs at Bernie
Sanders Bernie at the bottom of the
screen even though the numbers say he's
actually right there behind Biden and
ahead of everybody else in a
hypothetical matchup against Donald
Trump Trump the other thing is that
okay the graphics person at CNN made the
graphic the producer potentially
approved the graphic or maybe even the
producer directed the graphics person
about how it should be made but the
anchor Jim Sciuto could also have
noticed that hey this thing is out of
order
and could have pointed it out and Jim
shoot Oh either doesn't notice which is
concerning or decides not to point it
out which means he's complicit in the
entire thing truly lame very amateurish
and again whether it's deliberate or not
it always seemed to end up subliminally
making Bernie Sanders look worse let me
know what you think about this make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show and
while you're there follow me on
instagram as well at david pakman